pour cette dernière action de l'année le
conseil départemental des jeunes a
frappé fort et c'est sur la plage de
l'ermitage qu'ils se sont déplacés au
programme de la journée sensibilisation
à la réserve marine de la réunion
ramassage de déchets et sensibilisation
des passants pour les agents de la
réserve marine
il est important de travailler avec les
jeunes car c'est cette future génération
qui pourra faire bouger les choses
il faut donc les informer sur la réserve
marine parler de sa réglementation et
prendre connaissance de ce milieu afin
d'adapter ses actions et protéger au
mieux ce milieu qu'ils soient marins par
les récifs coralliens mais aussi
terrestres ces coraux sont la base d'une
biodiversité animale et végétale qui est
importante à la réunion c'est plus 3600
espèces d'animaux et de végétaux qui
vivent dans les récifs coralliens sur
des récifs coralliens sont pas très
grands 14 kilomètres carrés en moyenne
mais qui permettent par exemple aux
poissons de venir se protéger de venir
manger de venir se nourrir de venir se
reproduire donc si les corps ne sont
plus là on aura pu tous et toutes ces
espèces
un message que les jeunes vont pouvoir à
leur tour partagé mais on va essayer de
sensibiliser les personnes sur la plage
pour le dire déjà qu'il ne faut pas
polluer la plage qui ne faut pas marcher
sur les coraux parce que s'il n'y a pas
de coraux et à +13 marine il ya plus de
lagon les vagues pourront peuvent
échouer sur la plage une protection de
la réserve marine qui commence à un
ramassage des déchets présents sur la
plage fête en détruit un peu riol la
terre on peut lui aussi la mer ce qui va
aggraver la la santé des poissons et
ensuite comme les poissons sont des
aliments d'un qu'on va manger c'est en
quelque sorte on peut dire donc on en
train de polluer ce qu'on va manger en
fait de ramasser leurs déchets et c'est
pas du tout bien pour l'environnement
sur le secteur de l'ermitage ce sont 70
à 100 litres de déchets qui sont
ramassés par les agents de tamarone tous
les jours divisés sur plusieurs zones le
conseil départemental des jeunes s'est à
son tour attelé à la tâche
munis de gants et de boîtes ils ont
ramassé mégots capsules et autres
déchets afin de les comptabiliser avec
les jeunes on qui a eu sur une surface
de 160 m²
1959 mégots qui ont été ramassés et
environ 5 litres de déchets autres du
type capsules des divers objets en fait
en plastique après l'intervention de la
réserve marine et de tamarone les
médiateurs du tc au ont décidé
d'intervenir auprès des jeunes en jouant
un petit sketch incognito
alors je pense qu'on a quand même touché
les jeunes surtout que bah ils ont cru
c'était un peu énervé dans une pièce qui
se passe et tout mais on a touché un
petit peu je pense que oui la matinée de
sensibilisation pour une tricherie
ongles est avec l'environnement